انا مواطنه من غزه عنيت الحرب هذه بقمه
القسوه ومعي ست كبيره ومعي اطفال يعني هم
بيقولوا لنا اخلوا واطلعوا في اي مكان كيف
انا بدي اخل با اولادي الصغار وحماتي
الستي الكبيره وين اروح وين اروح احكوا لي
في مكان امن اروح فيه وقولوا لي وين اروح
انا من انا من جوا قلبيك قلبي بيغلي مش مش
من خوف من الموت احنا اللهم اني اسالك
شهاده بس ولكن انا خايفه على اولادي خايفه
على بيتي خايفه على اطف وال خايفه على
الست الكبيره قادر امشي
فيها هذا شيء بده بدك تجري وبعدين وبعدين
وبعدين احنا ايش ذنبنا احنا ايش ذنبنا
احنا ناس ابرياء وبعدين هي حماتي ما ح
جواز امريكي يعني فش شي فيش فش تمييز بين
الكبير والصغير والاطفال والبخ حرب حرب لا
ما شفنا زي هيك ما عمرنا شفنا زي هيك ولا
راح نشوف والوضع صعب جدا يا رب يطلعنا ويا
رب يقف معنا يا رب احنا في كرب في كرب يا
رب وقف معنا يا
رب